for massive steel pylons are sunk into
the floor of the North Sea they're going
to be the legs of the brave turn
their movement is controlled from the
bridge second officer purulia kotovsky
and captain Toni Cato are intensely
focused
a load of more than 20,000 tons is being
put in place centimeter by centimeter
it's a special moment even for an
experienced seaman we are slowly going
up and we are expecting to have four
point three meters penetration at that
location where the water def is 40
meters all this operation will take
approximately three hours before we
going to reach our working a cup which
will be approximately 30 meters the
brave turn is now a stable platform it's
being jacked up as they call it propr
cut off ski is not yet permitted to jack
up the ship but if he wants to become a
captain on an installation ship he'll
have to learn how like his boss
Englishman Toni Cato Cato has been in
the offshore business for five years
after we've jacked up we can remain in
position throughout any pretty much any
weather conditions we can survive what
we would call a 50-year storm I either
worst weather you would expect in 50
years so even if a 10 meter wave rolls
on past will be high enough out of the
water that it won't be a problem to us
now the installation workers get to work
they want to take advantage of the lack
of wind tower pods one two and three
on top of the towers go the turbine
housings
meanwhile on deck the night shift
workers have just got up they take over
in an hour Renee Frick cyl is on the
night shift he was a bun despair soldier
for four years then underwent additional
training he felt drawn to the North Sea
like everyone else who works here let me
get what I like is the 14 14 rhythm
working for 14 days than 14 days off you
can plan things at home you know you'll
be home in 14 days and you can organize
your appointments around this schedule
and you know that in 14 days you'll be
back on the job everyone here says they
earn a lot more than in their old jobs
on land but none of them are permitted
to reveal details on camera but it's not
a trade secret that room and board on
the ship of free
cooking is bugged and patents job today
we said schnitzel gold gurgaon blue
bogdan works alone on deck Rene Fritzl
begins his grueling 12-hour workday
picking up where the day shift left off
the crane carefully lift the 100-ton
carbon fiber rotor Renee and four
colleagues used special cables to
position it without bumping
renee has helped build 40 offshore wind
turbines he prefers working in the tower
to being on deck the huge constructions
have to be bolted together but today
others have done it but he does show us
some of his tools hi Lloyd Zika this is
a 90 centimeter wrench I think it weighs
about eight kilos turning it is hard
work so we use it in rotation you
couldn't do it all alone and that's why
not many women work in this business
it's physically very demanding well some
women do work on the brave turn nothing
here would function without the
stewardesses they make sure everyone on
the vessel feels at home more on that
next week